[Music]
this morning in our saturday session we
have a special tribute to this solemn
anniversary elvis perkins released his
debut studio album ash wednesday in
2007. more than five years after the day
that would affect him in deeply personal
and profound ways you'll hear two of
those songs in just a few moments but
first anthony mason spoke with him about
the musician's
this is your mom
where are you guys uh we're on the beach
somewhere i'm guessing it might be in
massachusetts and you can tell just what
a beam of light she was elvis perkins
mother barry berenson perkins was an
actress model and photographer she
worked with andy warhol shot covers for
interview magazine and life magazine she
took pictures of miles davis and louis
armstrong
in 1973
she married actor anthony perkins
the next year on the mike douglas show
she described how they met
i was doing interviews for interview
magazine at the time and i asked him if
i could go down and interview him that
was one of the pictures from the
interview when we first met they'd
raised two kids oz
and elvis
she was so very supportive and so very
loving to both my brother and myself
at times almost too bright
a light when we came along
she
put the camera down mostly and we we
became like her her life essentially she
was just a love supreme she was the
sweetest of the sweet and the coolest of
the cool she
once held a seance and of all the people
you could bring back from the dead she
chose otis redding
um
that's a great choice and you know her
life was tragically cut short but uh her
spirit lives on i'd be surprised if
she wasn't sort of in the room with us
right now yeah
20 years ago on september 11th
berenson perkins was heading home aboard
flight 11 when she died at the world
trade center
did you try to make sense of it for a
long time
i don't i don't think so i think i
realized pretty soon that there was no
sense yeah to be made of it
so the best sense i've been able to make
is through
the code
of writing songs
if not make sense of it just find a way
to hold it to contain it uh and the
place to put it therefore to bear it
yeah yeah
perkins mom had encouraged his
songwriting i remember playing for her
while you were sleeping which we will
play today and which she kind of helped
create
while you were sleeping
your babies grew
the stars shined and the shadows moved
right after it was done she was like
again
while you were sleeping
[Music]
the song would appear on perkins
acclaimed debut album in 2007
ash wednesday
have you been down to the memorial i
have how did you feel seeing it
there's it
it's not for me it isn't no i don't feel
like that i don't feel like she's there
no and when i'm there
i don't really feel like i'm there
and to tell you the the truth my my
first impression was wow that's a lot of
water they're using do we do we need is
that necessary yeah
i i don't feel the spirit there but you
feel the spirit in your music i do yeah
and just about
anywhere else
20 years later where are you with all
this you know i'm i'm in the celebration
of her existence she lived a fabulous
life
and she lived it fabulously as you were
looking at this
anniversary and sort of trying to figure
out how to process it
where did you get to
i got to it being a wonderful
opportunity to play these songs that she
got to hear
and that she loved and to essentially
use cbs's infrastructure to reach her
wherever she is yeah yeah that's that's
why i signed up to do this so you're
sending out wavelengths with these songs
indeed
yeah and i'm writing on your guys's
technology so thank you